you have a art with your brother yes
and you go to him and you apologize
and he says i i don't accept your apology what
what is the state of that good question there
are a lot of problems in churches because
members will not apologize to each other
they prefer to go gossip instead of following
matthew 18 15-17 moreover if thy brother shall
trespass against thee go and tell him
his fault between thee and him alone
if we would do that step one we would cut out a
lot of interpersonal problems in the church but
we call our friends we text this person we skype
that person we you know and we discuss it and
damage the person the biblical method is always
best if someone is offended you go to that person
it provides release for you and a chance
for the person to be free from the guilt
if the person does not accept you then there's
nothing you can do but you can try again
because jesus said seventy times seven he was
willing to forgive you can try again but if
it's clear the person is not you have done your
part and god accepts that because the person is
as much required by god to accept your confession
or your apology as you are to give it both things
must work but some people they wrap their arms no
i'm not accepting your apology that is not of god
the greatest offense is sin and god accepts our
apologies when we confess we're to be like him
all right that's the end of it my my brothers and
sisters may god bless you listen to me carefully
study the word of god please christ
object lessons page 100 paragraph one
the scriptures are the chief agency in the
transformation of character jesus prayed
sanctified him through thy truth thy word is
truth elohim white souls if studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart subduing
every unholy attribute when christ comes back
he raises the dead with the word until
then he will sustain us by the word
and take time to read the writings of ellen
white please god bless you wherever you are
if i come across your mind please say lord put
your words in that man's mouth god bless you